okay so if you haven't been watching
chess on YouTube for the last two days
maybe there's a small chance you don't
know who mins is
but this is a new
AI demonic Kitty that's been rocking the
Chess World my last few videos I've been
getting absolutely destroyed
by
mins who supposedly has a rating of one
but it's actually like three thousand
it's a very strong uh very strong engine
and in this video I thought it would be
fun to try and get revenge
and try and
destroy its soul
and I'm gonna team up with stockfish
here
uh so I'm basically cheating against
akin to try and and win a game
um now off screen I do have
a chess baseboard open with stockfish
please do not do this against human
opponents online I assume it's okay to
do against an AI kin
um so chess.com please don't ban me or
sue me
uh also mins don't Banner sue me I don't
think cats are capable of filing
lawsuits but uh maybe I should get some
liability insurance just be safe
so let's hop in and for one extra twist
in this video
I'm gonna try and get a Stafford Gambit
so not only am I going to try and beat
mints I'm going to try and humiliate
mittens
by winning with a Stafford habit
and I haven't tried this yet we'll see
how this goes
um it might take a few rematches to get
the opening that I want because mins is
known for varying the openings
and I'm going to leave the eval bar on
I assume more YouTube viewers like the
eval bar but let me know in the comments
if you prefer it one way or another
and uh okay I'll play
good luck we do have E4
are we gonna get a Stafford
I have three Knight F6
okay I don't need any assistance for
this we do have a software Gambit
of the main staffer can have it accepted
and we have Pawn E5
which is one of the main moves here
and in this position there's actually
two options for black there's Knight E4
and Knight D5
um against human opponents I usually
prefer Knight E4 because it's a bit
trappier like there's a trap of D3
Bishop C5 is already winning for black
and then there's a line of D4 Queen H4
is very venomous
but um after Knight E4 D4
the line is objectively
bad for for Flac I mean just the staffer
Gambit in general is bad especially at
engine level so I'm gonna go for Knight
T5 which is objectively
a little bit less worse
still better for whites but not by as
much compared to 94.
and okay we do have D4 and this is still
some sort of prep
um I know Bishop F5 is a move here
and the goal is to get a more
double-edged position
so Bishop E2
play Queen D7
let's see what mins wants to go for
very calmly castling the king
and um this is where like on my turn I
am letting stockfish think off screen
and I'm seeing the top five options it's
recommending
and in most cases I'll probably choose
the top move but there's going to be
cases where I might want to steer it
into
more sharp territory where maybe there's
a chance of um
exploiting the fact that mins can't
calculate at such high depth
so I like the move that it's suggesting
just casting Queen side guaranteeing a
sharp game with opposite side castling
and mins very quickly plays Pawn A3 uh
maybe preparing some Queen side
expansion and I'd really like to
generate some attack on the king side
uh there's a few moves being suggested
there's Queen E6 there's F6 there's
Knight B6 which doesn't make so much
sense
okay so I've let sawfish think for a
little bit and the top move is actually
Knight B6
but the second move is F6 I I think this
is a little bit more practical
just to try and chip away at the E5 Pawn
and if tix takes then the G5 will open
of course white does have C4 and now
we're pretty much obliged to play Knight
B6
but mince has to deal with uh Pawn
tension in the center
and there is a trail in F6
and now wow there's actually a few
options
um top move being Queen takes D4
can we get away with G takes F6
I think this is another case I'm not
going to play the top move
okay this is a fascinating line the top
move is Queen takes D5
but I don't want to trade Queens I want
to keep all the tagging potential I'm
gonna take back on at six with a pawn
uh C5 played this allows the Knight to
return to D5
now Bishop to F3
interesting so
mins is not uh learned basic opening
principles of developing the pieces uh
instead has been pushing Pawns
the bishop F3 is the only piece
developed
and
now
I mean I really want to generate an
attack stockfish is suggesting either
Rook G8 or H5
both moves look very fine I think Rook
g8's a bit more flexible
so let's start with this
Knight C3 okay putting more pressure on
D5
now stockfish recommending 97.
which looks weird at first but there's
some potential for the Knight to
maneuver
okay Bishop E3 played
and now Knight G6
at this point I'm I'm playing the the
top sawfish move mins plays King F1
let's go for a knight H4
this Knight is on a journey B4 played
okay things are getting sharp and we can
see based on the eval bar also based on
evaluations in chess base uh this is not
at all lost
and uh yeah it's like it's still
technically better for whites
but this is exactly the type of battle
I like to see
so now here there is one top move of
Knight takes F3 I'm I'm looking into
this line it actually looks pretty
concrete
but I already like the fact that we're
getting the bishop pair
and we're removing the the main defender
on the white king side which was the
lights for a bishop and we're keeping
our own lights for a bishop and now we
have Bishop G4
uh harassing the queen
Queen E4 played interesting okay let's
keep harassing the queen rookie eight
eval bar doing some uh some thrusting I
don't know
it's a good or bad thing
a queen D3
oh wow
wow stockfish recommending an insane
move here
now the winning move as far as they can
tell but
okay just really crazy from a human
standpoint look at this move Bishop F3
oh no my Bishop what's the point
oh
okay
Rook G1
look at this eval bar mins played this
move a few seconds later the eval bar
went straight in Black's favor
um I'm not yet looking at stockfish
this is black to move is there a winning
move here
is there a rook takes G2 or maybe even
Queen H3
are we about to crush mins with a staff
or Gambit
I'm gonna plug this move into stockfish
if you want to try and find the move
pause the video
but there's only one winning move here
and the move is Queen H3
overloading the G5 oh look at this
the queen cannot be taken because the
g-pawn is pinned and it's attacked in
three different directions
Queen F1
eval bar already saying Checkmate in
eights by force
and the the move to start with is
absolutely insane involves putting
another piece
on a square that's attacked by a pawn
look at this move Bishop D6
oh no my Bishop a threatening mate and
more importantly connecting the Rooks so
after Pawn takes Bishop
just verifying here
we're gonna take on G2
this is crazy
and mins playing a spy check
Pawn D7
uh we can just take that
I'm pretty sure I can finish off this
game without stockfish but Rook G8 next
I'm not even plugging these moves into
stockfish because I feel very very
confident
there goes your Bishop
men's is very silent here
I think you're realizing it's fate
and now Rook takes G2 but even more
forcing is
actually how to do this bishop takes off
three and then we win the queen
but what's the force meat maybe Rook
takes G2
G2 is just cruel
but also kind of cool Rook G2 Knight F6
or Knight C5 and then the king will be
safe
and um at saying made in three I'm
pretty sure this was the way to go
King C8 no more checks
not even spy checks
wait is there no me here it's made in
two it's not there's no Maiden one
though
um any Rook move I think is
horse mate
uh let's just torment it Rook takes H2
double check
and then Rook H1 checkmate
what has been saying what how you CH oh
is it is it accusing me of cheating
maybe I should sue it can I sue a cat
also I did kind of cheat I was using
sawfish
thank you stockfish
uh shout out to stockfish15
uh even stronger than mins in this game
so not only
did we defeat
the ever so powerful men's
but men's has just been crushed by the
staffer Gambit that was a 30 move
victory
oh it feels so good let me just replay
this game
and uh watch in awe so Knight D5 is not
the move I normally like to play
but look how quickly this went in
Black's favor
officer side castling
played Pawn F6 broke down the White
Center
open the G file
and this night maneuver this night
started
I mean this was a Stafford Gambit night
uh it started on F6 went to D5 went to
B6 came back went to E7 G6 H4 and took
the bishop
all within the first what 18 moves
and once we remove the bishop
even mins couldn't figure out how to
defend
yeah the queen got pushed away
Bishop F3 is so satisfying
and yeah I think like Queen H3
um
it wasn't spotted because it requires
higher depth
like for an engine to to fully
understand this line it needs to to see
like five moves ahead and see the
sacrifices of uh Bishop D6 and Rook G2
uh so so sweet
instant replay Bishop D6
and their Rook G2 oh man
okay GG I feel like my life is complete
beating mins with a staffer Gambit